foreign
[Music]
you have an apartment building on the
other
the target destroyed the whole
infrastructure of Ukraine destroyed
infrastructure on our hometown they left
people freezing in the winter less
people do it without electricity they
need the Russians want to make the
humanitarian catastrophe in our hometown
and also at the same time destroy the
buildings it's not the first one the
apartment is building in our hometown
where I killed the people
we have more than 200 Apartments
building destroyed from the Russians
attack we killed a lot of people
civilians and guilty people and that's
why it's a terror attack and Russians is
their entire country I'm more than sure
do you see the unguilty people killed
every day in not just on Keith
everywhere anywhere
we want to ask our partners we need the
safety right now the main priority for
everyone in Ukraine and that's why and
the record system we need to meet in our
hometown to uh to bring this safety
feeling to every citizens in our
hometown
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
this morning again here under a Russian
attack therefore it's very important
that we respond decisively from the
inside and from from outside for me it's
very important that we establish a EU
military training mission to Ukraine and
also that we release more money for
supplying Ukraine with weapons and not
least also weapon systems that can
defend themselves against these attacks
we see at the moment
foreign
last one
in Chicago
um
it's just